Film Courage: So then (if I understand this
right) that FINAL DESTINATION was the first
screenplay that you actually sold?
Jeffrey Reddick: That was the first one I
sold.
I wrote one and it never got made but I was
actually hired to write a sequel for a movie
called PUMPKINHEAD, which is one of my favorites
and they are remaking it now and so hopefully
I can use my sequel idea for the sequel of
the remake but before I got an agent, I got
hired because Brad Krivoy was the producer
and he was taking pitch meetings and I wrote
a pitch that he liked and he basically hired
me and another writer to finish the rest of
the script and then the company got bought
by somebody and all of this so neither one
of our scripts ever got made but no, that
was my first paying job as a writer (which
was fun).
That was a little crazy because you are like
“Wow!
I am writing something that I grew up loving.”
That was the first thing that I actually sold
and I’d written like 5 or 6 or 7 scripts
before A FINAL DESTINATION that never got…and
rightly so for some of them when you go back
and read them, it’s like “Whoah!
These are pretty bad.”
But there’s a couple of nuggets of ideas
that I might turn into something some day.
Film Courage: I’m just wondering how did
it happen?
What were the details?
So you are working at New Line Cinema they
had known you for years…
Jeffrey Reddick: They had known me for years.
I was trying to get a TV agent and then my
friend Mark Callen was like “Oh, this would
make a great idea for a feature.”
Back in the day you could actually sell a
treatment to a studio.
You didn’t have to write a whole script
and because I worked at the studio, I knew
how when the winds would change very frequently
so something would be hot one week and not
the next week.
I was like “Let me write a treatment, because
it’s a great concept.”
And some friends of mine worked for a producer
outside of the studio that had to deal with
the studio, so I’m like let me go work with
him and their producer partner and bring the
idea back to the studio because I knew that
would give me a better chance of getting that
set up (it was with the producer attached).
I had the treatment and then they were all
grown ups and then SCREAM came out (and I
love SCREAM) and Kevin Williams is a dear
friend of mine.
And the minute that came out it was like “Let’s
make them all teenagers.”
I had to go rewrite the treatment to make
them all teenagers and then the studio just
couldn’t get their head around certain aspects.
They were like “It’s great.
It’s cool but how can you make certain things
happen.
It just doesn’t make any sense?”
And I’m like “That’s the whole point
to having a horror film.”
So the studio just kept passing on it and
finally the producers (it was Warren Zaid
and Craig Perry) they were like “Well, if
you pass on it again, we’re going to go
to Dimension” which was kind of New Line’s
rival, Miramax at the time.
And they were like “We’ll buy it!”
Film Courage: You said the magic word.
Jeffrey Reddick: So then they bought the treatment
and then they hired me to write the first
draft of the script and then we went out to
directors after that.
It was a pretty quick process.
We sold the original story in ’97 and the
movie came out in 2000, so in Hollywood time
that’s pretty, pretty fast.
Film Courage: When you did the casting for
it, how did you find the lead?
Jeffrey Reddick: Actually New Line did all
the casting through there casting department.
I’d put my list together of my dream cast
at the time.
But I love the cast that we ended up with.
And it’s funny because I’m friends with
Devon (Sawa), he’s directing now and he’s
got a new TV show so I produced his first
short that he did and he’s a really talented
guy.
We’ve actually reconnected in the last few
years and he’s just a great guy.
It is funny because when I was writing the
movie I was kind of (you know) trying to turn
some of the tropes on their heads and so there
are very few movies that have a final guy
in it, it’s always a final girl.
So I wanted to write a movie with a final
guy in it.
And his character I think definitely stands
out and he’s such a great actor, too.
He did such a great job and he was CASPER,
too.
It’s always funny making fun of him because
he was in CASPER floating around in with Christina
Ricci when they were kids, dancing ridiculous.
Devon, if you’re watching this, ridiculous.
Film Courage: I would see him in so many things
because I used to go into Blockbuster Video
all the time and I just remember “There
he was again!”
[on a DVD cover].
Jeffrey Reddick: Yeah, we was really hot then,
too.
I think he…ah man…there is something North?
I’m blanking on the name of it…there were
some coyotes and people in the wilderness.
I’m trying to think of the name of it, I’ll
try to look the movie up…but it was a really
big movie.
It was CASPER and then that one, he did IDLE
HANDS…I think IDLE HANDS…I don’t know
if that was pre or post FINAL DESTINATION…I
think it might have been point FINAL DESTINATION.
But yeah, he was definitely on everybody’s
like ones-to-watch-list.
And we shot it in Canada so was got a lot
of Canadian talent, as well.